all right very good Thank You Roger like
Roger said my name is Jonathan worked on
the our Studio IDE for almost three
years now along with jjo lair and Joe
Ching some of the other authors what
we're going to be talking about today
like Roger mentioned is team
productivity in our studio server Pro
now if you know much about our studio
server Pro or you've used it in the past
you know that most of the features we've
we've allocated to the probe product
have typically been primarily for IT and
administration and so we've added things
like monitoring good authentication
we've added logging and and most
recently we've worked on auditing but
for the most part if you're somebody
who's actually using our studio server
Pro once you once you're logged into the
server it doesn't feel a whole lot
different to you and in this release we
were really excited to have been able to
take some time to address that so all
the features that we're going to be
talking about today are features that
you can see and use as a data analyst as
somebody who logged into the server and
uses it to actually get their work done
the goal of these of all the features is
we're going to be talking about today is
to help you and your team be more
productive a couple reminders before we
go on first of all all the features that
we're talking about today are they're
all brand new none of them have been
talked about a whole lot before they are
on our web page but they're part of a
brand new release of our studio server
Pro that you probably don't have unless
you've recently upgraded in the last
couple of months so this is all brand
new stuff and it's only been out for a
short period of time we're also not
going to talk about all the new features
in our studio server Pro we're just
going to talk about three main ones look
at look at those now so the first is
multiple session support this is a
familiar that is probably a feature
that's probably familiar to you if
you've used to our studio desktop we've
now brought it to this server so you'll
now be able to run multiple versions of
our at the same two person multiple
sessions if are at the same time we'll
talk quite a bit about sharing projects
and collaborating and pair programming
and other things that you can do with
your team and the new version of our
studio server Pro
and finally we'll talk a bit about
multiple our versions which is a really
nice feature not everybody needs this
but for those that do we think this is
going to be be very powerful so as we go
through each each one of them I'm going
to spend a little bit of time talking
about it and a lot of time demoing it I
won't be able to answer questions during
the course of the demo but we will have
some time at the end like Roger
mentioned to go back and answer any
questions you might have that have come
out during the demo let's talk first
about multiple sessions so multiple
sessions is sort of like having multiple
our studio windows up at one it's only
instead of being on your desktop it's on
the server this lets you do a lot do
long-running jobs while you do other
work which is fet which is a really
useful thing to do for instance if you
are somebody who ever works with a with
an R script that takes a long time to
run you will no longer have to wait for
the r script to finish in order for you
to do other work with our studio you can
actually create multiple our studio
sessions and then switch between them as
easily as you would switch between
desktop windows and I'll show you how to
do that in a moment in addition to
allowing you to do multiple long-running
jobs we've engineered this feature so it
can serve as sort of like a master
control panel it's very difficult to
keep multiple desktop when it was open
but it's actually very easy to keep
several sessions open on the server
because they don't take up a lot of
space or compute time and so it'll be
very easy for you to really create your
own master control panel with workspaces
that are warm and ready to do image your
common Edel analytics tasks so I'm now
going to switch over to our studio
server Pro itself this is a this is a
brand new install of our studio that
I've created just for this purpose
so one moment will I switch you over to
that alright so here is our studio
server Pro this is just a quick local
install that I've created so I'm going
to sign in here as our studio user and
Here I am so in order to demo the
multiple session feature I'm going to
start by
doing something that takes a long time
to do just to keep things very simple
this thing is going to be sleeping we're
going to sleep for about two minutes so
here now our Z and I can't use this our
session for anything else because it's
busy performing this incredibly long run
in calculation which I expect will take
about about two minutes so so while that
runs I'm going to go to the server
homepage now this is another new feature
in this release of our studio server Pro
so if you're our studio seems like it's
missing this it's because you haven't
upgraded yet so this is the this is a
dashboard that I was referring to
earlier so this is a home page it gives
you quick access to all of your projects
and all of your active sessions you can
choose whether you want to see it right
after login or whether you want our
studio to just jump into your last
active session when you log in let me
show you how to do that really quickly
so to go back to where it was I can just
click on this particular session right
here again think of this like a desktop
window that's running our studio I can
go to tools options here and you can
choose when you want to see this if you
want to see it all the time or if you
only have multiple sessions to choose
from etc let's go back to the home page
now so this dashboard gives me a view of
all of my active sessions again think
windows on a desktop and then all of my
active projects right now this is a this
is a brand new server so it did I don't
have any projects will create some will
create some it a bit but what would I do
they will be listed here so this our
session as you can see it is busy
running something but I'd still like to
do some work with our studio so I'm
going to create a second our session to
do that so I'm going to click this
button right here the the plus that says
create a new session and Here I am so
this this is a new session my other
session is still running I haven't
terminated it and in fact it is still
running in the background right now you
might be wondering well how am I going
to know when that when that session is
done so I can go check on the results do
I have to keep switching back and forth
into this in this admin screen or not
and the answer is that you don't now
you'll notice it now I have two sessions
here the one the one that is still
executing and my current one here I'm
going to dive back in the one that is
not executing
I the same session list that is
available in the server homepage we've
also build it right into the IDE itself
so you'll notice right up here in the
upper right corner I've got a sessions
drop down and this is going to allow me
to check on in on all of my sessions
without jumping into that page so I'm
going to click sessions here and you've
got two of them that one that was
formerly running is now idle so I know
that it's done with its job now if I
were to start a job here now I'm going
to jump back into this session and you
can see that the other session there is
now once again running a running code
and I can I can see that it's busy and
not finished with this computation just
yet so we think that this is probably
that really the most useful feature of
sessions is it lets you do more than one
thing at a time
however sessions also have a couple of
other interesting features one of them
is that they can you can use them to
create a sort of lightweight mini
project let me show you what I mean so
let's say that I've got an R script that
I want to run against some data so let's
make some data we use the empty cars
data set let's make an R script that I
want to run against that data so it'll
just create a summary of that data set
then we'll run the script there's the
results very simple now if I'm somebody
who has to do this particular set of
analysis pretty frequently I can just
leave this session by itself I'll go
I'll go back here to the home page I
could just leave the session running and
whenever I need to whenever I need to do
that particular data analysis task it's
very easy for me to jump back into this
session and there's all my data and my
scripts in my code and my console and
everything just the way it just